you
okay let's give this computer another go
on chess comm I'm gonna try to games
against it and the time controls are 5-2
so all right let's see if I could
establish control the center or stay
claim to the center here with my pawn on
d5 so going with the kingside fiend keto
and well alright we're gonna go for this
aren't we
I'm gonna capture on this square Queen
c2 a6 Catalan yes there's other moves
than Queen takes here but that's the
line it's going with so it's a very
committal move I get in b5 though and
now I've weakened these two squares and
the big idea is to somehow get in c5
this pawn is backward and my biggest
liability so how do I deal with that
first things first this pawn is hit and
I think Bishop here's the right idea to
neutralize that pressure so let's go
with it and white is okay with this
capture the I could double the pawns and
it may seem like there's a weakened King
position but it's not really a position
that's accessible I can't really attack
it so I think just develop night here
hmm I already miss play this now I was
thinking maybe instead of the bishop
here I should have played Bishop to e4
first alright let's see what other moves
to consider right here's the top one
right here
if efore then maybe I take
all right like I think the night needs
to go here it's it's natural it's good I
don't I want to keep this pond free to
move it watches over this square Wow
okay now bishops head what's wrong with
just taking I have to watch out for this
now the Queen is maybe gonna sink into
that sea six square so this is an
interesting move I don't think I do well
to do anything but just capture is there
some other consideration mm-hmm all
right let's go with that now I have to
deal with the Queen maybe getting into
this square this is tricky yeah this is
gonna this is gonna be tough no I know
it's gonna be difficult to dislodge it a
piece once it's on c6 if one day this
night could somehow get in here that's
gonna be a pain so maybe I can work
around a queen or a rook but a knight
getting here will just kill me all right
so any move I do to try and prep this
advance is gonna be met with Queen to c6
it's no fun hmm maybe I should look into
another pawn break maybe if I eliminate
this pawn this c5 move be a little bit
easier to get in maybe I could do Queen
e7 and then push here I'm weakening
these squares though that Knight will
kill me one day on f5 not so easy hmm I
mean I could just queen here to here
this pawn is just it's forever a
liability I'm gonna go with this it's
such a pain yeah look at the pressure on
this pawn what a bug I just keep this
tension maybe you know if this capture
ever occurs I take with the pawn I have
to worry about them anymore could view
it like that what do I do in the
meantime though how do I I progress here
this advance in and then after it takes
I take with the knight I
be something about let me go with it to
keep my [ __ ] up around right here there
goes that night bump my queen up well he
could still go there
the Queen's there to watch over it
really wasn't expecting that Wow
take with the Queen there's night tempo
yeah moves what's wrong with just bishop
takes that and that really surprised me
take with the bishop he's still
liability yeah I knew that I knew he was
gonna go there
wow this F v square is gonna crush me oh
wow okay where else should I go with my
bishop should I move my bishop my bishop
there's a knight here to f5 you see
these this is definitely not the type of
position to get in against this computer
where you have to calculate it but
there's all these open lines I was
hoping for something much more closed
but it clearly did not happen I'm under
a minute and okay let's see what do I do
with this guy
back him up let's let's keep hang on to
him they're gonna be night here stuff no
playing on both sides of the board huh
okay maybe it's just playing for time
maybe it's just playing for time I don't
want more lines opened up don't really
think that that's the best move but I'm
gonna have to just go with it I guess
maybe we could just try for a queen
trade I have an easier time playing you
know we got that one okay can I hold
this one to a draw that's my big
question it's gonna be very difficult to
do very difficult to do that let's give
that night a kick
alright oops I got that increment though
living on the increment uh-huh rook here
is nice yep there goes one pawn and soon
others are gonna fall feel it definitely
feel it alright let's get my rook active
I'm not giving up so easily
let's do this Knight here next yo he's
gonna kill me nah
that's it I'm just gonna I'm gonna be it
I'm just not gonna resign I'm just gonna
let it in like that I'm down on time
hand position the big threat here is a
fork and also just the threat of
capturing here with the fork here can't
defend against both I'm pretty sure and
I'm down upon let's try one more that
was terrible I need to get a better
position to work with one that's closed
so let's let's go with this there's
something more positional the more open
the position the more difficult it is to
beat this computer yeah alrighty so Slav
land is that what we're entering okay
let's go with III maybe I go after the
bishop if he's coming out there alright
maybe let's develop the knight first and
what now Queen here let's do that can I
have the pin maybe I could get it in 95
and pick up the bishop maybe 95 c5 I
don't like c5 c5 Queen here if I had my
bishop outside the punching I'd really
consider this but not now I think this
is a fine reply after c5 Queen c7 is
good and then after 97 it's difficult to
stop the e5 break
so what other thing can I be doing the
Queen's are in tension with one another
Knight e5 comes to 9 tempo on the bishop
eventually he's going to get challenged
though with Bishop here not here
maybe I should still be doing that let's
let's see where the bishop is gonna go
Bishop f5 okay I think I just have to go
with some fairly tame moves Bishop to e2
mm mm I guess let's just develop and if
97 do I play f4 do I take I really think
I want to take I don't want a week in
this square this light square bishop is
outside the pawn chain and just I play
me I think black would have a very easy
game if I weakened my e4 square by
trying to support my knight on e5 would
be different if this bishop was back
behind the punching but I'm not so big
this f4 move so I think since I can't
support the night that I should probably
just take him out at least force black
into retreating and now just follow-up I
think I have to do what exactly I would
like to get in this advance that's not
so easy to do though
what's my darks for a bishop gonna do
not sure that's probably the only square
he could go to okay the Queen's are off
all right so now maybe I could shoot for
something like F 3 E 4 hmm or F 3 yeah F
3 how do you stop Eve for maybe there's
just a counter strike in the center but
then you're gonna have pressure here I
want to keep this tension it makes life
difficult for these brakes C 5 and E 5
for as long as I keep this tension I'm
fine if takes here then it's undone my
pond so I'm looking at f3 and you know
and I also have some concern about the
bishop playing the c2 to attack this
pawn it looks as though I'd have to come
back here but okay if f3 and night here
and then g4 I could kick the bishop
around in the night around I'm gonna I'm
gonna try this trying to expand in the
center and and there goes the night okay
I think this is fine g4 Bishop c2 I
think I have to come back here so okay I
have control over this 9th oh this pawn
it's very very good and boxing out this
night I can't really give that pawn up
can i okay let's do this I'm gonna back
and forth no okay hang on interesting
that really is interesting
all right let's let's induce some
weaknesses here I'm threatening to trap
this bishop or no not really wouldn't be
trapped it has this square - hmm this
Bishop is a bug he's a real pain maybe I
could get my knight in to f4 that might
not be a bad square it seems like a
pretty good square I don't want to do
this because it weakens g5 maybe maybe
the knight or bishop can make use of
that I'm thinking about rerouting my
knight and now I'm kind of giving up on
this Eve for idea all right there's just
too much control over it hmm I can't do
this my rook is unprotected after takes
I can't recapture so thinking about 92
to f4 let's go with that yeah that
stopped I see but maybe I'm still gonna
go there yep
let's go they're still pawns are doubled
but I get the bishop pair I could
support this okay that pawns hit huh all
right well now I don't want to give up
the bishop pair so easily I was thinking
about this move I get my king working a
minute's free doesn't matter how much
time I set the initial controls to this
things I was gonna fly so I've weakened
this square significantly the Knights
ready to jump in there yeah what can I
do about that
well I think I'm gonna have to try and
stop the knife from getting in there I
mean I always get there by way of g6
night here and it figured that was gonna
come why not you know I think I have to
take him out I cannot allow a piece to
get here so look at my structures and
beautiful it's one of the most beautiful
structures you will ever see hitting the
bishop is their way to hold this alright
let's keep rolling here is it savable
okay it might be savable no no no if I
do this there's pawn push and if I take
the rook takes with the check I maybe
did that one too fast yeah you know the
rooks are gonna get so active yeah I
didn't do well to stop those rooks from
getting active but you know what maybe I
could still kind of play this on let's
see is this savable I run over here with
my king
I'll Bishop here maybe let's try that oh
man why didn't I see that move okay I
got a take no time to think my King
needs to come over here oh man alright
let's take that guy out what's the big
trick with that okay oh I'm in a giant
knot I am definitely in a giant knot
let's do this pawn push these pawns are
gonna get picked off one by one and you
see as soon as there's a rook over here
on the fourth-ranked can this be held
this truck is just way too good way too
good run pawn save the day somehow rook
check figures that's my only hope
look at that rook water monster what a
butt a bishop he's gone ah there was
nothing that I could have done well
maybe there was something I could have
done but this game is long beat oh that
was so painful man I'd even come close
in either game ah man
this wasn't hold a ball was this just
the wrong idea I got back here we're
trying to get a essential expansion in
with F 3 and E 4 how I'm talking about
after after this F 3 move our half of
excuse me after the Queen's are off the
board mmm what a bug that Bishop was
yeah this just isn't a good structure
maybe you know what the other idea I
could have maybe gone for instead of
this more committal g-form move yeah I
was that was too weakening this maybe
maybe as soon as this as soon as I
kicked the night air force the night
maybe that's prevent this e4 advance I
should have stopped with this idea of
trying to kick around the black pieces
and shut down the Queen side with c5 and
then tried to get in b4 b5 the next
break I would have to watch out for
would be c5 then as soon as soon as
there's no more pressure on this as soon
as I'm playing c5 this is the next good
pawn break for black but they'd have to
go back with the night yeah I think that
was a better a better attempt instead of
this lashing out type of move with g4
and the other thing I guess to keep in
mind would be what it would be that you
know I'm not having to react to these
threats of the bishop coming down to see
to g4 Bishop here stuff like if I have
my pawn up he's gonna I do I do this
move with the intention to play up to
here so maybe that's the direction I
could have gone and there should have
gone in yeah that was a very weak oops
I don't know it happened there that was
a weak while two games in a row but uh
all right well nevertheless it does
happen often like that and as always I
hope you got something on this video
take care bye
you